if you were trapped in a horrifying
futuristic video game what would you do
each day you stay in this world you'll
transform into your in-game character a
full-on coldblooded psycho killer and
the only way to escape will be by acting
like Abraham Lincoln vampire Hunter
cutting eggplants and utilizing
2,000-year-old War tactics done by
badass British queen Warrior these are
the only things that will help you get
out of your alive I'm going to break
down the mistakes made what you should
do and how to beat the futuristic
totally innocent death games in Overlord
this game is about to find out who the
bad guy really is and it's not what you
think these Heroes prepare for battle
against this skeleton army they charge
in but get brutally slaughtered by the
real hero of this story eyesin he is a
veteran player of this futuristic open
world game called yd drasil but [__] has
hit the fan and the game is about to
close down 12 years later all of his
video game friends have now left his
Guild and he stays behind to enjoy his
last gamer moments wishing he could just
play for one more day but he doesn't
realize that he'll now be able to play
this game forever he goes to chill with
his servants say boss here the Butler
and his battle mates 1 minute left until
the server closes and he messes around
with one of his minions named albo
changing her settings he makes her fall
in love with him classic anime before
preparing to exit the game but suddenly
he can't get out he thinks the server
shutdown must have been delayed but he
realizes that he now can't access his
virtual menu or contact the in-game
support and that's when he hears
something terrifying he's never heard
before in his life albo's mouth starts
moving and she addresses a directly
something that shouldn't be possible all
the maids and seos now have a mind of
their own and even a pulse freaking his
tits off he cautiously orders sa us to
go check outside and see if anything
strange is happening desperate for
answers on what's going on he grabs
abdo's busty you know what and sees that
he can now do anything his little heart
desires and he comes up with a new plan
to escape but this innocent world isn't
ready for what he's about to do to
achieve his goal Gathering up all of his
minions like AA and Mari he figures out
that he can still use all of his powers
but can now do it with just his mind
looking at his servants he realizes that
he might be in trouble because they
aren't video game characters anymore but
real people with complex minds and that
might just betray him if he pisses them
off nervous he pretends to still be a
badass leader while he comes up with a
plan to contact the game administrators
but he will soon find out that it won't
be as easy as he thinks with the no
family or no social life in the real
world if he can't contact the outside he
will be trapped in here forever but it
gets worse actually Seas suddenly
reports back on what he saw and they now
have a bigger problem the map they are
now in is completely different to the
original game they don't recognize where
they are even a little bit and there is
no life outside within a 1 km radius Ein
realizes that they must been transported
to an unknown world but he doesn't know
why which means something is
horrifyingly wrong preparing for the
worst he orders everyone to fortify and
conceal their headquarters immediately
until they figure out where they are why
they're here and what terrifying enemies
they'll have to face in order to escape
but Ein quickly realizes that his mind
is starting to change the longer he's
here he's now starting to feel more
robotic and each time he gets emotional
something inside him is now forcibly
calming him down even if he doesn't want
to like he's becoming more coldblooded
he goes for a walk to try and take his
mind off of this weirdness and that's
something that's going to cost him soon
enough okay while this seems like a
hopeless situation I'd be able to help
us and you get out of here by using
medieval torture techniques they're
wonderful the kind of techniques that
would have your parents ashamed of this
Channel and by acting like our favorite
vampire Hunter Abraham Lincoln let me
explain the first problem here is that
we just came from the greatest MMO RPG
game into this even better looking game
CU it looks just like real life which
makes this a huge problem because that
means this game would probably have more
than just relationships with be Druids
having hot babes that you cannot touch
and vice versa and where everyone is
horny 24/7 this game is more epic than
that this is why to figure out what's
going on and not to die I would talk to
one of our lowest ranking minions here
and commit brutal acts of degradation
and violence using the most famous old
school 12 to 14th medieval torture
techniques on them we're not just
killing our people for funsies it's for
our survival we need to see what type of
damage our minions would take because we
need to know the true Stakes of this
death game if we die here what happens
then this is why we got to figure this
stuff out right because no one's going
to come to save us but it's really not
that simple and here's why as a video
gamer now turned real life leader this
job could seem intimidating and
downright scary since we have no real
job experience but we might be able to
pull this off thanks to science these
guys basically ranked a ton of History's
Greatest leaders political business
military into two categories ones with
prior experience before they got the
leader job filtered leaders and the ones
that didn't have any experience at all
before they become a leader unfiltered
leaders okay and they found that the
most effective and highly ranked leaders
were in order one unfiltered Leaders
with no experience filtered Leaders with
experience and then unfiltered leaders
make sense this means that people with
no experience on average either do
insanely well at being thrown into jobs
without experience or insanely bad
compared to people with experience who
are more likely to be good but not great
at their job because of their in the-box
thinking means that they would make
decisions that most people in their
situation would make anyways the pros of
having a filtered leaders is one that
they're Dependable but they're stuck in
their way of thinking while people like
Abraham Lincoln or Steve Jobs people
with little to no experience before
becoming leaders makes them which is a
pro more likely to have outside of the
box perspectives they more adaptable and
they can likely thrive in better
emergency situations or they might crash
and burn immediately because there's no
in between there and that's actually
great news for us and others who lack
experience because if we suddenly get a
leadership role that means we got hey a
5050 shot of doing his job really well
since being a leader even in life isn't
all about experience but how adaptive
you are to your environment and that
means our confidence right now might
literally just save us all H suddenly
finds out some bad news he can't contact
any in-game support because this is now
real life which means he can't direct
message anybody Thinking Fast he figures
out his next plan that will guarantee
him to help him Escape the game contact
the other unknown players who might also
be trapped in this world like him by
conquering this new world and making his
famous name so famous that it will reach
everyone in the game by doing whatever
it takes facing fluffy monsters enemies
from his own game and traitors from his
own team coming up soon elsewhere
trouble is brewing this guy is planning
to attack a village a little later he
tries to figure out this world's map and
uses this magic miror of his but spots
trouble this Village and its citizens
are getting slaughtered and eyes is
shocked but not that these people are
dying because who cares about that
seeing all the blood he actually feels
nothing and he actually likes what he
sees ignoring this huge red flag he
can't be bothered to save this Village
since it's not going to help him escape
the game since someone once saved him
like this years ago and decides to throw
them a bone and test out his powers as
the enemy he'll soon have to face is
actually closer to him than he thinks
arriving he quickly saves this little
girl by breaking these men's Hearts
literally and Slaughters everyone in his
way and feels nothing nothing casting a
spell on this corpse he turns this bad
guy into a zombie minion and orders it
to go Slaughter the rest of the knights
just like that moment you finally get
the dual blades and Assassin's Creed it
is glorious oh I love it and meanwhile
Alo arrives to join the Bloodshed eyes
offers this little girl a red health
potion and a horn blowing on this will
call a goblin army to come protect her
if she's in trouble telling her his
cover name is eyes he orders her to
spread the news of what he did cuz he
needs to become famous so other players
can find out about him as soon as
possible and his death Knights keep on
freaking ripping apart these dudes heads
popping more blood spewing the dead man
Wonderland after a tells the strangers
here to address him as his cover name a
sparing a few of the bad guys he warns
them to spread his Legend throughout the
land as soon as possible he then gets to
work and finds out more news about this
world how to escape and what enemies
will stand in his way but that's when
this Village Chief tells him what he
wants to hear if he wants to become more
famous than one punch Man or Superman
for example he must take on one of the
most badass jobs that you and me has
ever seen and must become an adventurer
Legendary Heroes that hunt monsters and
flesh eating beasts to become one he
must go to a nearby city called IR onel
but he knows becoming Adventurer will
also help him reach his second and even
more important goal to meet other real
human players trapped in this world like
him and that's when their conversation
is cut short by the sexiest looking
Warrior Knight stud GF stron he says his
men came to save the village but thanks
a for picking up the slack and that's
when they hear a Sinister Rumble and
something approaching them that will
shock everyone especially our hero to
the core the group takes cover while
eyes analyzes the enemy which are magic
casters and their positioning and
notices they from the slain theocracy
which means more trouble for him these
guys are the Special Forces Unit they're
basically like if Harry Potter and David
goggin had a love child knowing these
guys are is tough as magical balls he
calculates their odds of escaping alive
until the captain here suspects they
want him dead but that's when ey spots
something that makes his skin crawl and
the one thing that will make him
question his reality he spot some
enemies and he recognizes that this
belongs in his game okay so we're
surrounded all sides but this actually
tells me the bad guys here are complete
losers and the reason involves rat traps
cutting eggplants and the illusion of
Hope Ice here is not feeling any
emotions like we've talked about when he
saw all the death for starters and that
tells me he has something that 15 of the
most famous serial killers in US History
also have in common psychopathy and
here's why and how it can help us get
out of this situation Psychopaths
clinically are defined as people that
don't possess certain emotional
responses for example a lack of empathy
and basically can't control their
behavior the thoughts of wanting to kill
your boss or school teacher or Mom that
one time might have actually happened if
you're a legit psycho I's not feeling
any emotions about seeing blood or
horror isn't the big problem but the
fact is that he still feels other
emotions like horniness and happiness
for certain things and this makes him a
psycho because unlike what most people
think Psychopaths actually have emotions
they just have more of certain types of
emotions joy happiness horniness
surprise disgust while having no
feelings of understanding other people
meaning they will have no problem
staring at you in the face while they
literally cut you a thing and that is
what I here is basically becoming a
Willie cutter or a cucumber or a
eggplant whatever you prefer but his
craziness is something that we can use
here when you combine it with the fact
that we're surrounded but this actually
tells me the bad guys outside are really
pathetic amateures here's why if you
trap a rat in a box right above
someone's belly button and start hitting
up the box from the outside the rat will
start doing its way into your belly but
and this is because it has nowhere to go
we fight like it has nothing to lose and
do whatever it takes making it more
dangerous than normal the same applies
here the enemy has made the Tactical
mistake of showing us that there is no
escape and now realizing that we are so
freaking overpowered they are going to
die so quick prepared to die for his
nobless cause the captain here heads out
to fight his enemy while Ein secretly
watches what he's really up against
handing him this doll is a gift he
doesn't reveal what it really is heading
out the captain charges against the
enemy and puts up a good show deflecting
blocking encountering all types of crazy
Magic but gets quickly overwhelmed and
brought to his knees tougher than one
punch man and cocaine bear he spits in
the face of these overpowered bastards
and he is about to die but that's when
he gets teleported back safely into the
village thanks to the magic doll a gave
him a can now finally figure out where
these bad guys came from from his game
and he's got to hurry because he's
running out of time to save his soul the
Angels attack him senseless but he
reacts quick and sees these creatures up
close confirming their creatures from
his game and he demands to know why this
bad guy can use powers from his game but
he ignores eyes and keeps on attacking
and here's basically the Epic 5-minute
battle that goes like this attack with
an angel it didn't work sir well attack
with all Angels still didn't work sir
fine I'll use this bigger Angel uh
should we Retreat sir I have one less
trick up my sleeve summon an even bigger
Angel cuz you're stupid and that's when
the commander then whips out something
that is definitely from M's game this
magic item and seeing this he actually
gets alerted that this time he might not
actually win against the enemy and he
quickly uses ba as a shield of meat
blocking the attack but for some reason
he also lets the Survivor bad guys run
away as long as they spread his name and
doesn't inter interrogate them at all
what a Chad he stops back at his
headquarters but Alo has more bad news
and says they still haven't found any
new players but are expanding their
search hin now thinks that his minions
are acting more useless by the day and
tells them to be better now realizing
that he's quickly becoming his ruthless
in-game character in real life he rushes
off to the town of AEL to register as an
adventurer now going with his battle
servant Nai they try to rent a room but
this one guy then tries to start a fight
with him and accidentally breaking this
redhead girl's potion H notices her
Adventure rank is higher than his bronze
so he offers her his own red potion in
case he needs her later now an adventure
he stops being mysterious and tells his
group their full-on mission poses young
adventures but secretly gain knowledge
about this world using their new job
privileges as they rise up in the ranks
and get access to more top secret
knowledge about this game which will
actually help them escape this world at
least that's the plan because if only
were that easy he warns them they
shouldn't reveal who they really are
until they find all the real human
players first in case one of them is
even more psychotic than n and that's
when he suddenly realizes he's screwed
because uh they have no money oops rich
with currency from their old game is not
going to work here they need to take up
an adventurer job as soon as possible
because they are broke meanwhile this
redhead girl thinks something is wrong
about the red potion I gave her she's
never seen this potion which means it's
sus as hell taking it to this Magic Pawn
shelf this guy checks out the potion and
is shocked because of its color it's
nothing like he's ever seen before red
means it's basically made of God's blood
and is basically one of the most rare
items in the world but that's a huge
problem for Redhead here if anybody
finds out she's got it she is going to
die back at A's location
chats with some locals and they invite
him to join their hunting party but what
Ein doesn't realize is that he's talking
to dead man walking this guy asks na out
but she says she'll cut his tongue out
and he thanks her for her ruthless
rejection about to head out he gets
invited for a job by the man I doesn't
realize he knows him nefa he off signs a
job but doesn't tell him the real reason
he's been hired and the job protect him
while he collects a bunch of herbs for
his potions in this really dangerous
Forest nearby which will defeat by using
2,000-year-old boss babe Warrior tactics
soon in the next 3 minutes traveling on
this dangerous Journey they get the
breakdown of their opponent a silver
four-legged Beast tail of a snake and
smart and can use Magic on the way s guy
here jokes that since she has na
rejecting him she's probably dating a
cuz pretty girls can't be single but Nai
gets annoyed and slips out that a is
already dating someone named Alo putting
eyes on edge and warns her to keep her
big fat mouth shut and it's going to get
him killed if she doesn't watch it if
Fria doesn't catch the importance of
what just happened not realizing that as
they speak this psycho girl Clementine
is working with this dangerous Poli kaj
to kidnap him within the next week
suddenly they spot monsters unable to
avoid them a Rees up and directs his
team to handle the front while the
others take care of the stragglers that
just get through attacking ogres and
slicing nasties taking these two on and
boom phito chilling out Ein takes a sec
to remember his old Adventure guilt
making him determined to do whatever it
takes to escape this game even killing
innocent men but more on that later they
continue their dangerous Journey while a
is worst nightmare works on tracking
down to friia with everything now in
place she plots her attack that will
cost the death of hundreds of lives
including these adventurers because
they're going to create a zombie army
and take over the city of irel and use
the Zombie Army to help the priest
become immortal great by collecting
death H's crew reaches a new city carav
Village but get ambushed by goblins a
brutal battle is about to happen when a
familiar face shows up nefa and a
recognize her enry the girl that he
saved and gave a goblin horn to at the
very beginning but who's also nfa's wife
not recognizing him with his mask on
eyes decides to keep his identity a
secret but nefa basically gets told how
enry survived the attack on her Village
and she tells him that her savior had
someone named albo with her and he
pieces together that her savior is
actually a rushing out to confirm this
fact with a himself he comes clean to
nefa thanking him for saving his village
he agrees to keep his real identity safe
and also comes clean about why he hired
him he wanted to learn how to make the
red potion and use it for good and eyes
agrees to help him if he keeps his real
identity a secret focusing back on the
main epic story they head into the
lethal Forest so nefa can collect his
silly herbs and they stand the lookout
for creatures that guard this area the
wise King of the Forest a tells his
minion AA here to help him find and send
the creature his way so he can defeat it
in front of everybody cuz he gosh darn
it wants some Glory searching around she
finds it and pisses it off and makes it
attack the group of adventurers just as
a once getting closer it announces its
presence and warns them to leave before
it rips them apart for lunch I would
rely on beating this thing by taking
lessons from a Roman forc battle that
happened 2,000 years ago and a badass
ancient British babe that took out
70,000 soldiers because first off we
they don't exactly know what we're up
against but conveniently here's its
strengths but did you just catch what I
just said these guys rushed in without
thinking too much of what they were up
against and it's super obvious even if
they are badass it is bad advice to show
people if you are ever up against a huge
ass monster in a futuristic video game
because it would first help to First
maybe understand their opponent without
risking their safety for literally no
reason and they could have done this by
easily reading firsthand surviv accounts
if any on the creature or asking around
town and compiling notes on the monster
along with something so important that
it caused some of the greatest armies in
history to crumble in fear prior
operation research should have also
included Forest topography research and
finding where their enemy lived and
study the specific Forest that lives in
because here's the thing any great
military commander from General to
Lieutenant since the dawn of time will
tell you that Forest Warfare is about
the worst thing there is and we can look
to history for hard evidence on this
like the Battle of tberg forest in 9 ad
three Roman Legions tried to crush a
tribal Rebellion but their armies got
strung up along a forest trail for 7even
Miles they couldn't do any of their old
battle formations and literally all
16,000 soldiers either ended up dead or
getting sold as servants for another
time the ancient British queen bua leted
a revolt against the Romans in 60 AD
with the help of the forest obliterating
70,000 Romans with just a handful of her
own men before dying it's crazy and that
is because fighting in the forest as
anybody you're going to come into issues
with heavy concealment risking ambushes
flank attacks disruption of logistical
support or simply getting spyed on
that's at heavy concealment and it gives
the enemy the chance to watch us at all
times before striking the point is
fighting in the force sucks which is why
we going with a better plan to fight a
monster we know little about by luring
it to the edge of its environment doing
this will shift it to our advantage
because the monster will struggle to
fight in an environment it's not used to
charging at them to eat their flesh they
discovered this monster is actually a
majestic hamster sir hamsu confusing
eyes he tells hamsu his old allies
before had pets just like him and he
gets excited and asks where others from
his race are according to anime rules if
he doesn't pop out some babies soon he
will fail as a living creature tell me
about it but anyways a has no idea what
he's talking about and they go back to
fighting and he quickly defeats huk into
submission and wonders how such a cute
little fluffy creature could be so wise
and dangerous and makes hamsuke pled her
loyalty to a now that boring mission
complete they drop Nefera back to his
house and tells him that he'll return
once he registers hams Su with the
adventure Guild heading inside nefa no
this is his grandma isn't home but
someone else is Clementine she sets out
her terms to destroy the world use nfa's
powers to help her create any kind of
magic item for her and use him to summon
an army of the undead for this priest
and that's when the priest appears and
they prepare to have some fun with him
meanwhile a finishes retesting at the
guild but meets nfa's grandma and
something seems off rushing back they
arrive at something worse than anyone
imagined the slaughtered corpse of A's
fellow allies now turned into zombies
cutting off heads a notices nfa's
untouched belongings and suspect this
wasn't a rock robbery but a kidnapping
instead because whoever did this didn't
care if they were found since they were
confident they could get away a says he
will find nefa only if he gets paid
though and Gran gets super pissed off at
him but she is forced to hire him and
his team and he spots one important clue
that will solve it all all of his old
Partners former Adventure plates are
missing likely collected as souvenirs
piecing together the clues they rush
back to the one place where zombie
Creations would come from the biggest
cemetery in the area rushing there they
saved the town's guards about to be
overrun by thousands of Undead striking
and dicing the flesh eating monsters
making their way to the bad guys's
Hideout nabe carries hamsuke into the
air to avoid the undead senser heartbeat
while eyes guides them through the rest
of the army knowing they'll never make
it in time a creates Jack the Ripper
corps's magic spell to help him out and
they make a very quick push further
inside spotting Clementine Ein tells her
he found her because the bronze copper
plate she stole getting in the way of
bigger plans she handles eyes while nabe
here stays to take on the wizard
arriving at this empty area Clementine
tells him how she loved to make men
squeal but I says hey he can't judge her
since he reveals he was also going to do
the same thing to them ruining her plan
she gets ready to kill him nearby wizard
summoned this big ass Dragon but Nai
does something really cool gosh I'm
nerdy out right now she ties her sword
to her Hilt and she announces that she's
going to beat this drag like a baseball
bat knocking it down the two duke it out
the priest fires acid and she fires
lightning summoning this badass power
the full power of the orb of death he
uses up his energy but nabbe still
overpowers the dragon and shocks the
priest and it's so freaking cool
meanwhile eyes goes at it and learns all
of Clementine's moves as she makes them
having an idea he Ys out T Nai to
transform into her true form nabo Gama
turning her into this Beast she cuts the
dragon with super speed and wipes out
the priest's 5year bagy plan in
literally 5 minutes that's pretty rough
for him destroying him eyes then tells
Clementine they need to wrap this up
because hey this video needs to end he
grabs her into a be hug and Reveals His
True face and power and squishes her
like a baby does a small pet squeezing
her slowly and tells her to stop
struggling and go slow and while she
squirms and crushes her spine and wins
beating this beist bad guy and they go
to save nefa and take over this mind
control device and put him back to
normal meanwhile E's crew hit up IR onel
to look for people who can do magic
tracking down someone e can use for his
escape plans using some sick methods to
find his location but then hear about
someone named Brain capable of such
Powers Sab us then leave Shaler and
solution and head somewhere else to
gather information doing her job sheler
man eats her way through these men and
tracks the scent of their man cornering
him she announces that she's here to
capture him he puts up a good fight and
escapes leaving her to his men which
pisses her off and she finally
transforms into a full-on vampire it's
pretty nasty and sucks their souls
finally getting near she spots enry and
the red potion she's carrying finding
out that she got it from Iron not
wanting the survivors to get away and
reveal who she really is she gets ready
to kill them but runs into these magic
casters and quickly gets mind controlled
that is something I was not expecting
the news spreads to a of what just
happened he's lost one of his best
warriors and everyone thinks shaer has
rebelled against him but a knows this
can't be true and thinks she must have
gone mind controlled but it shouldn't be
possible for NPCs to get mind controlled
and he sets out to find her and find out
how and why this this can happen with
NPCs or else his headquarters nazer will
be at stake but [__] has already hit the
fan the next day he gets called in by
the adventure Guild they tell him what
he's worrying about a vampire appearance
in this city is just happen and all
members must stop her before he gets out
of control eyes must save Shaler before
they kill her and he plays a cool and he
tells the member that he's actually been
hunting down this vampire for months and
already has plans to capture her
claiming he could handle this job alone
and he offers his conditions he wants to
level up his Adventurer rank when he
completes the job and the leader of the
guild accepts but there's one dude
demands to tag along with eyes to help
him annoyed eyes lets him but on the JY
later double crosses him and kills him
in Cold Blood it's pretty awesome and
uses his minions to do his dirty work
because no one can find out who Shaler
or him really are he orders them to
bring back his body to headquarters to
experiment on because maybe they can
turn him into a highlevel zombie servant
on the lookout they eventually spot
sheler alone in this field and eyes uses
a spell on her to remove the mind
control but it doesn't work horrifying
eyes and this means a world item has
been used to mind control sheler since
it's the only thing that can defeat A's
spell escaping before it's too late he
returns to headquarters and orders Alo
to raise their base security level as
soon as possible because everyone here
is in danger he also calls his Guardians
to return immediately to prepare for
what's coming okay it's so obvious he
was walking into a trap because of where
Shaler is there's a much easier way to
at least try to get an edge before
battling her shty here makes it obvious
that she's trying to lure him in in the
middle of the battlefield but before
showing up there I would have first
tracked down and looked into the area
where she got brainwashed as we might
find some Clues here hello even if we
didn't one thing's for certain going up
to ask her who was responsible for all
this while she was brainwashed and now
probably against us means she probably
would not have told us anything anyways
which means a is strong but he's not
that smart but there is a bigger problem
eyes thinks that sha tier's mind control
spell was caused by another player
currently hiding in this world arming up
they head to their Mausoleum to acquire
the only thing that can protect them
World level items the strongest weapons
in the game meaning the caretaker of
this place Pandora's actor he looks
through his Arsenal but reveals to
Albero that he wants his minions to use
these Ro items to protect themselves
while he actually handles shaer all in
alone because he's the only one who can
defeat her heading back solo he notices
the person mind controlling Shaler isn't
there confused he combines all of his
powers of magic and Blaster but she's
still standing and he's like yeah [__]
now transformed into full battle gear
she chuggles but then gets confused of
what she's doing and questions her
actions like a crazy person suddenly
turning evil again she attacks a and the
two doke it out all except one sheler
pulls out some moves a has never seen
before forcing eyes to amp up his moves
with Precision she then takes out a
special move taking out all evil animals
killing them immediately while she gave
their health into hers and she pulls out
this move and attacks a and makes his
health level low about to kill him a
reveals that he's used a false data
spell basically making it seem like he's
low on health and powers and even
pretended to be shocked by her skills
because he's so freaking overpowered and
it's awesome because he actually knows
all of it cuz he went through all of the
NPC settings way earlier his nerd ass
knows all about them while they're
capable of and he levels up into a
warrior form and uses all his weapons he
picked up earlier finally defeating
Shaler with the strength of his Guild
fast forward a bunch of hodge podge
later moments eyes resurrects Shaler but
she has no memory of what happened and
reveals that his Butler seos was
actually bait this whole time and was
instructed to go and lure in whoever
mind controlled sheler because now they
will likely Target him eyes orders his
Scouts to patrol the area where saos is
because they will find out which real
human player is out to get them and in
doing this escape this game before it's
too late and before eyes Turns full evil
but what do you guys think about the
video let us know what you like about it
and what you didn't like about it don't
forget to like subscribe and leave a
thumbs up down below and as always don't
forget to check out our how toe playlist